hi there steve kaufman here we're still
early in the new year
today i'm going to talk about writing
but before i do that i want to remind
you that it is early in the new year
i've done a few videos now
even in japanese encouraging people to
be enthusiastic and to make the
commitment and we talked about setting
goals for you know your new year's
resolutions and it reminds me of the
joke about the guy who said you know i
joined the gym a year ago and i'm still
not feeling any fitter so i decided to
go down to the gym to see what was going
on like in other words he joined the gym
paid his money and never did anything
a lot of people joined gyms at the
beginning of the year and never do
anything
now is the time of the year to make a
commitment to learning or to improving
in your language
everyone can do it with the right
attitude with the enthusiasm by the way
at the end of this video there will be a
link you can click through and get a 40
discount on an annual membership in link
annual membership is the way to go
commit for the year but don't do like
that guy and then never uh study commit
for the year and then work on it every
day now writing i talk a lot about
listening and reading and speaking
and i say that listening and reading is
what's going to build up your vocabulary
improve your familiarity with the
language get the brain used to the
language
speaking you have to speak a lot in
order to be able to speak well now what
about writing
now i have to admit that the only
language where i have to write or had to
write a lot was french in my own
personal situation
and all the languages the other
languages that i've learned including
japanese when i lived in japan
uh i didn't need to write
and
but writing is a very useful way to
improve your language skills
uh in my chinese when i was learning
chinese and i had to write the british
foreign service exam i had to be able to
write a diplomatic note in chinese so
that was a requirement of the exam but
in real life i've never had to write so
depending on what our needs are we may
not have a need to write i lived in
japan i can't write i can't
write by hand in japanese i can
communicate you know via email using uh
you know computer software and the same
in other languages however
writing is so key because when you are
writing
you have the time
to look up a point of grammar that
you're
concerned about which you can't do when
you're speaking when you're speaking it
just comes out and when you write you
can review what you have written and you
can find mistakes because we do make
mistakes and sometimes when we review
something we've written
we'll say well we're not sure about this
i'll look it up or we know that this is
wrong and we can correct it
all of those things are not available
when we speak so writing is a great way
to sort of improve your accuracy in the
language because as you correct those
mistakes in writing you start to ingrain
some better habits so
i i have to admit that i don't have the
patience to write i just like to get my
favorite podcast and listen to it and
maybe get on youtube and talk to someone
or
read something and but i'm not i have no
need however
you know where writing accuracy comes
into play
if you're if you're working and the
language of business is
the language that you're learning
then there is a greater requirement for
you to be accurate especially in letters
but even in emails if if you write poor
english or spanish or chinese it sits
there people look at it it creates a
poorer impression if you're speaking to
someone your back and forth thing you
you can tell especially if you're
looking at the person you can tell what
they mean they can tell what you mean
it's not so crucial when you write you
have to be more accurate and so
writing is more demanding
um
now how do you get to write better you
know
this is the big question so i say to
speak well you have to speak a lot
uh to increase your vocabulary you have
to read a lot to develop some momentum
for your speaking and for your reading
you have to listen a lot now to write
well you have to both read a lot and
write a lot
so reading a lot because when you read
you're going to
get the words and the phrasing that you
need
because you don't have it within you
and then when you write you have an
opportunity
to look at what you've written and
correct it
um but but writing is more than that
writing is as i said earlier it's a way
of improving all of your language skills
if you have the patience to do it
uh and of course there's several aspects
to writing if you are learning a
language which has a different writing
system you have to begin by getting used
to the letters or in the case of chinese
and japanese they're characters so there
i think for example our dictation
function at link is very useful i used
it for greek i use it for arabic i used
it but i gave up in hebrew but that's
where you can hear the text to speech of
a phrase
the phrase you saved and then you have
to type it out so that's one way of
getting used to
the writing system however to be able to
write well to use words accurately to
have natural phrasing with fewer
mistakes you have to read a lot
and sometimes you hear people talking
about business english or academic
english i don't really see
that such things exist
but
you know if you're speaking to someone
in business
you know if i'm doing business in japan
in lumber i have to know the terms
for lumber that's all the rest of it is
not business english we're communicating
it's our japanese rather it's just
japanese so in your normal communication
with people there is no such thing in my
opinion as business english or business
japanese but in the written form there
is because there's a way to structure
your written communication the same is
true with academic
english or japanese if you read a lot on
medicine or whatever your area of
specialization is you will acquire
those
technical terms and the rest of it is
basically the language however
it's it's in structuring that
communication that you need to develop a
certain skill set
when i was in france at sean's post
lance d to do politik political science
institute they had a very
definite set
format you had to use you had to have
the introduction and the first section
the second section and the conclusion
and in the first section it had to be
balanced two parts a and b and in the
second section which was often sort of a
refutation you know refuting the first
section or expanding on the first
section but also in equal parts and then
finally a conclusion so this was the
format that i had to use it doesn't
matter what format you use but when
you're communicating in writing you
should have some sense of how you want
to structure it so that what do you put
you have to basically let the person
know what you're going to talk about
early on because they don't want to read
through this long screen to find out at
the end that you want to have a meeting
with them you better put that up front
but then how do you structure that and
what are the reasons you give and all of
this you should have a plan for and i
think there it is useful to read
and hopefully in your target language
because these
conventions can be different in
different languages it's different in
french in english and japanese and so
forth read up on how business
communication academic communication is
structured so that you have that sort of
formula in mind and then it's easier to
write whatever you have to write a
report or a letter however the actual
language used consists of
language
plus whatever technical terms
are you know relevant to that particular
discipline
however if you're in that discipline
you're likely to know those technical
terms or if you don't know them you
better learn them but the bigger issue
is
getting the structure of your
communication correct and then of course
acquiring the words and phrases that
make written
the written language flow smoothly you
know i wish to point out or whatever it
might be and these phrases you have to
see them often if you're on link you
save the phrases you review the phrases
so you build up your written language
with these phrases
and finally i have found when i do write
in another language i consider it an
extension of my speaking so i try to
avoid speaking in a foreign language in
a very sort of slang casual
colorful way i try to speak
a neutral form of french spanish
japanese whatever it may be and then i
use that same
form of the language when i write so
that the actual the language
sort of uh itself is more or less the
same except in writing you're going to
be more specific you're going to be more
concise you're going to go back in and
correct things you're going to try to
conform to a certain structure so you
have to pay more attention and that is
in itself a very good discipline for all
of your language learning so
as we head into
2020
uh you know commit to your language
learning
maybe if you have the time and the
patience do more writing and of course
sign up for a year at link using our 40
discount
and again we'll see you
next week bye for now